♪ (TENSE MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
LOGAN ROY:
Thank you all for making it.
We're gonna be the number one
media conglomerate in the world.
The key here is act like
a happy family.
We're the Osmonds, and I'm
Daddy fucking Warbucks, okay?
Good, fine. Nobody here has any
glaring substance abuse issues
that almost brought down
the company, right?
♪ (MUSIC INTENSIFIES) ♪
REPORTER: How are things
between you and your dad?
Um, pretty good.
He looks demented.
Why is he so shiny?
I always wanted one of you kids
to take over.
People would do well to remember
there's gonna be
a new sheriff in town.
Well, he asked me to run
the company. I'm kidding. Am I?
-Hey, Shiv.
-Hey.
Your sister's
just in for the day.
-Just to observe.
-Observe what?
Can I suggest you look
for some down time?
-(GRUNTS)
-Dad, you okay?
Maybe you should sit.
You're old.
I do what I want.
We are going after Pierce.
Us trying to buy
the most respected name in news?
-LOGAN: We're gonna fucking
eat them up.
-Delicious.
-Let's bag this elephant.
-Let's bone this turkey.
WOMAN: Welcome
to our funny little house.
You have an interesting family.
I have an offer.
Watching you people meltdown
is the most deeply
satisfying activity...
on planet Earth.
We aim to please.
Everybody, stay in your lane.
-Fuck!
-Stop! Security!
Back off! This is
executive-level business!
LOGAN:  We're coming up
to the finish line.
Cut the horse shit.
Know your role.
And remember... money wins.
Here's to us.
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪